well it's like a mindset because you can
see the good in anything yeah because
you think a new laptop yeah
i think it's like just don't make
everything into a crisis like it just
doesn't need to be you know there's uh
gabrielle fell while hiking the other
day
adam was chasing me
he was chasing me and red car um was
trying to defeat blue car but blue car
still won
but she had stitches and you know and
but first of all she finished the hike
you know we didn't just turn back we
finished it you said i could though yeah
but but it was a mindset right it was
yeah it was it didn't whether she got
stitches or had a hole in her knee as
long as she was wanting to keep doing it
why wouldn't you keep going but i would
say if we knew the energy if we knew the
extent of the energy in an injury we
probably thought yeah we should take you
down carrying it
but we didn't and you know and then we
kept going we just went to the er we got
it stitched up and you know we went to
went to the next place so the whole
point is is it's just a mindset to just
keep going just keep going did you do
you guys feel like there's problems that
come with success
like there's problems walking across the
street
when it comes to like jealousy and that
sort of thing
i don't know i think people are i think
people are jealous of happy people
that's more true
really i don't care if you're happy or
anything
yeah cause somebody's always somebody is
always there to knock you down it
doesn't matter and so you can't let it
bother you
i mean you just can't it's like okay you
did great well good good for you
the trouble you have is that it doesn't
matter it's not not about
success it's about anything in life
somebody will you can't like i guess
even with you you know the comments are
probably bad you can't it
something's gonna be give you some nasty
comments what life's about
and you gotta just say hey you know what
whatever just move on
i think when we started the business you
know when we were not yet successful all
of our clients were successful that's
why they were buying software and so i
think we had surrounded ourselves
accidentally probably by a lot of
successful people and a lot of happy
people and so
it helped us aspire to that um but just
in general i think that there's always
people that are
you know wanting to take you out so you
know if you just drown out the noise it
goes back to the exact same thing it's
like it doesn't matter what they think
that's right you just gotta look back
look at life and say
it's for you to make the most of it out
of it how you feel and by doing that you
gotta again follow your passion don't
worry about whatever else thinks if you
worry about what i thought i mean if i
he asked my advice for you i'd given you
initially are you nuts
i never told you that but that's how
internally i just don't understand it
and that's but that's okay though but
you you do understand it and you
followed it and that's that's great
that's that's what you want to do and
that's what all your siblings want to do
whatever whatever it is
i mean i mean eva eva is like so much so
much talent that it's like so many
different things that she's just so so
good at and just follow the one you end
up loving just and that's and that's why
i would gladly help you help her help
anybody because even chaz okay
and that's the point because it's your
passion that has to take you in life
because you're not happy life sucks
you're not happy and don't have your
health life really sucks
i've seen so much of it in my own family
so my my brothers and sisters was like
oh my god
and so that's what i'm saying those two
things you've got those two the money
doesn't really matter it's those two
that are
so
yeah hannah you had a i saw something i
that you put out there and you said
you were at a private banking event and
you're with all these wealthy people and
you were the youngest person there and
probably in
the world the eyes of the people in
there you were the most
wealthy person because you were you had
your youth on your side you had health
on your side and you were really happy
that was a fun event
no that's true because i was thinking
about all the money in the world can't
buy your health and it can't buy youth
no and so if you don't
um if you don't have your health
um
like i i think that's the saddest thing
to be honest and like you have and
that's why i think sometimes like in
this world we forget how lucky we are
just to like wake up every morning and
not be in pain right
i think i thought about it when i broke
my leg in 2014 like you know i couldn't
walk they told me i would never run
again without a limp and i'd never walk
i've never walk again without a limp and
i'd never run again and nine months
later i ran the chicago half marathon
and i just decided i was gonna do it and
i went about it like a job and i you
know the doctors told me to start
physical therapy in six months i was
running in six months
and so
i just yeah we do it different in the
davis household
but that leads to her other points no
other point is that she had a great
physical therapist
and that's the catch you got to have the
people surround the people around you
with good people
so if you do that then it makes your
life easier well and i took ownership of
my my health and that's the other thing
right now i think our medical care
system wants they want control of your
health and they want um you know and
they want you to just surrender it well
had i listened to them i can tell you
that everything they predicted would
have been true
but i just that wasn't for me and i
wasn't going to do it that way and so
you know my point on that whole process
is i had a fantastic physical therapist
i went to my doctor and i said if i was
a professional athlete how would you
treat me is this what you would do well
then after much heating and haunting
they finally said no this isn't what we
would do i said okay well my health is
as important to me as a as a
professional athlete is and so you know
went through the whole process but what
was remarkable is i finally got through
all of that and it was horrible i
couldn't run i mean i couldn't drive i
couldn't do anything but then like one
year later i saw flashback come up on
some social media site and
it was like wow i have forgotten to wake
up every day and be grateful for just
walking
and so you know i think we just become
so
in grateful um
for what we have and our you know our
health is what we have
well um i just wanted to say
publicly thank you guys so much for all
you do
um because honestly like i'm so grateful
to you guys because i wouldn't have
built this show without you and you guys
were so supportive when i would cry all
the time
well you're welcome and small bills work
just fine
yeah i've mostly forgiven ellie for
pooping in the house yeah yeah and even
like um i don't know there was just in
the past couple of years there were
times where i really wasn't in the best
place and you guys like supported me so
much and like helped me out of that
um and so thank you so much for helping
me build the show my original sponsors
you guys bought my first soundboard
[Laughter]
um so i'd like to go around i know we're
hot and we want to get moving on the
road so why don't we just go around and
if anyone has any last like thoughts
they want to say or anything
um
i just wanted to start by saying thank
you so i love you guys you guys are my
favorite people in the world thank you
yeah you too
oh he actually admitted you are the
favorite hannah
i go back to my original question you
asked earlier i have no favorites
it's a competition he makes us compete
for it weekly
i can be bribed
it's like survivor
no i don't have anything
chance isn't always this quiet by the
way
well it depends what year chad's are we
going for like is it 2020 2018
there's different types of trousers
eva do you have anything you want to say
got to keep the health dad how's your
coca-cola doing
right afterwards
after we're done melting
i'm all wrapped up thanks for having us
on hannah yeah thanks for coming guys
appreciate you all
yeah thanks mom and dad for bringing us
here
it's always a pleasure